[Music]  my flock this will not be a war of  Heroes nations well slaughter each other  why are we late  this is going to be fun  [Music]  you cannot keep me locked away as the  world burns  son the truth is the world is rule  by corruption and greed  we must do something certainly  [Music]  we are the first independent  intelligence agency refined but brutal  civilized but the masses  welcome to the club Harris fellow it's  time to pour fuel  [Music]  of the fire of revolution yes I should  welcome Englishman Rasputin your  reputation precedes you  [Music]  what say this as gentlemen after all  [Music]  manners  my  why is it the boys are always so messy  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]